hey guys what's up this is andrew from
trendysenses.com
so very quickly for those who are
watching my videos for the first time
let me quickly introduce myself
i'm a professional trader and i created
my youtube channel a few months ago
to show you guys everything that i know
about training
so i mostly talk about technical
analysis but
it's not only about reading the charts
it's also about reading the flows
which is for example the option open
interest other short interest that you
can find
on any stock so let's do an update of
this numbers on amc
and see what these numbers are telling
us let's get into it
[Music]
so the first thing this is my chart so
once again i won't go
through all these drawings here but you
can see that my scenario is quite
bullish
so of course this is just you know a
guess
and i can be wrong but you know this
is what would make the most sense to me
so basically i think that amc would go
to 35
in this first cycle then we'll see what
happens it will depend on the copy
crisis
on the vaccines if people still want to
go to cinema all the stuff
but for now we are developing in this
five waves move
and for me target of this first cycle
is 35 all right now the reason i'm
bullish so i gave you the reasons you
know the technical reasons
already you have some bullish
divergences you have you know all the
indicators
except for the volume that are pointing
towards the same direction which is
bullish
and one of the reasons as well that i
talk about sometimes but
maybe not enough and it's very
interesting i think to keep an eye on it
of course i do but i think you guys may
want to understand
exactly what this data means it's about
the option market so let's have a look
at it
so to analyze the option market you can
find all the information on yahoo
finance for example
and you basically check the number of
call options that are on every strike
and every maturity right so here are the
strikes
i go up to 40 because this is where i
find a lot of
open interest and i take all the
maturities so thirties of april
is you know put to zero already this has
expired
but i take seventh of may until you know
september so i have all the maturities
here so
this took me a lot of time i went on
yeah finance and i got all this data for
you guys
but you know checking the open interest
so for example you can see that
randomly you know i take the 10 strike
on the 14th
of may not on the 7th of may you have 15
000 open interest so you need to
multiply this by 100 to get the total
number of shares sitting at this strike
then uh we need to make some assumptions
we're going to suppose that retail
investors
are actually those who are buying those
collapsions which is i think a very good
assumption you're gonna see
why i did this assumption version and
this is not enough you know to only
compute this
the total open interest you're gonna
find that
if you sum you know for all this
maturities for every strike
and you sum up the total open interest
you're gonna come up with
a number that is the maximum number of
shares
that retail investors are gonna be
longer if actually
these options finish in the money but
what is interesting to do at the
beginning
is actually to see the exposure so the
maximum would be 15
if all these options actually finish in
the money
but when we are trading at 10 you have
an
associated delta for each option so let
me explain what is the delta the delta
is the exposure of each option
for example if you take an at the money
option
you're going to have around 50 delta
which means that you have 50
chance to finish above the strike level
at the maturity and you have 50
chance to finish below your strike level
at maturity
the delta has a formula that depends
also on the volatility
which actually creates some higher than
50 percent
exposure for the money options when the
volatility
is very big but i won't go too much into
detail here
and using this formula you can compute
the delta of each
option once you do this you can sum
all this exposure for each maturity and
each strike
and actually come up with the total
short exposure
that is on the option market and this
data is very interesting to
actually use because it is a short
position that is not
seen in the regular short interest that
is published on finra for example
and for now when amc is trending at 10
this number is
5 and what i like to do is to check
where it is coming from because on a
regular option market for example like
apple
and it is very interesting to actually
see where it's coming from
so for example you can see that on the
4d strike
the total number of shares is the
biggest all right this is the yellow
curve that is here but the exposure is
not the biggest because once again this
is an
out of the money option so you can see
that the yellow curve is the highest
here the highest point is at the 40
level
but the red curve which is the exposure
is actually the
highest at the 10 level strike but
imagine that we go for example to 20
and you're gonna understand what is a
gamma squeeze see
how it changes so this one has not
changed much
but this one has increased the yellow
curve has not moved at all
and now let's imagine we go to 50 for
example
now you can see that basically the red
curve is converging towards the yellow
curve
here and that the maximum
exposure is going to come from this 40
strike and the synthetic shot is going
to grow
from five percent to 15 percent it's
going to converge towards this number
because all the delta is going to
converge to one
and this is actually what can create a
gamma squeeze because once again
remember what we said at the beginning
of the video we assume
that this option positions are held by
retail investors which means that
professionals like market makers or
hedge funds actually
showed this same cool options so
if the investors are getting more
exposure because the delta is increasing
because the probability of finishing
in the money is higher then the market
makers are going to see their short
position
increasing as well and they're going to
be forced to buy some shares in the
market
this is the process of a gamma squeeze
and this can only happen when you have
this out of the money strike
levels that have a huge position
in open interest and this is the case
for amc
as i just showed you another information
that is very interesting to look at
and i'm going to do this for you guys
because i'm an option trader is to
monitor
the volatility of this very high
strikes so for example right now for amc
the the volatility of the 40 strike for
the june maturity i'm gonna stick to the
june maturity for now because it's more
stable than taking the
you know one week maturity and for now
it is
226
so this is very big
this means that market makers need
to have protection against this scenario
and to get protection what they do is
they increase the volatility that they
use to
price this option and another thing that
is very interesting to notice
is that you can check the delta once
again by using the formula i showed you
so let's
go back to the initial scenario where
amc is at 10 like here
and you can see that the delta is
basically the probability to finish in
the money like i said
for example for the 40 strike and during
maturity by using this very huge
volatility of 226 percent
the delta is 50 guys so it means the
market makers
give 50 chance for amc to trade above
the 4d level strike in june
it is huge and let me just give you an
example imagine the volatility is 30
like a random stock okay then the delta
is zero so you see
the higher they put this volatility the
higher the delta
is for 50 still zero
if i try hundred and fifty percent
now it's twenty four percent you see so
if the volatility goes too low
this is the reason why it is an
indicator
of what professionals think for example
with a volatility of 130 percent they
think that there is a 17
probability that amc is trading above 40
in june but right now guys like i showed
you the volatility
is 226 percent which
gives it a probability of 50 of
finishing
above the 40 levels so this is a very
interesting information for you to have
and you can only have it by
understanding
how the option market works this is why
i wanted to show you that guys
now we're gonna do something even more
interesting
we're gonna check the short interest on
amc
since i started my youtube channel so
since november
and what we can see guys so i take all
the information here
we can you can see that the equity float
moved from 80
million shares to 400 all right so we we
know that
there was a lot of shares emission but
the short interest
grew as well especially in the last
months guys
there were 50 million shares short in
the market so
hedge funds actually you know sending it
we know that
and now it's 90 million so the short
interest increased just in the past
months from 12
to 23 so this information shows you
that they cannot help but selling it
you know hedge funds just think that amc
is overvalued and
you we can see that the fight between
retail investors and hedge funds is
starting again because they are
increasing their positions for example
for gamestop
i'm going to show you guys very soon but
this number is stable
so the battle is happening on amc right
now
and this is why amc got actually
hammered in the past week
you know it's quite easy to understand
it's just hedge funds putting pressure
but
we know that someday it is game over for
hedge funds
and basically the way those guys work is
that they follow some data
and they have some triggers that are
gonna tell them that they need to buy
back
their shorts and one of the data they're
gonna follow
and it's not only the traders it's the
managers of those guys so you know they
basically have no choice when this data
is
showing them the signal to buy back
they're gonna do it
and the date i'm talking about is the
dtc which is day to cover this is the
meaning
and it's basically how many days it's
gonna take to cover the shorts
if they trade roughly the average volume
so you can take the average volume on
one month or on one week
and if you take the average volume on
one month and you assume that they need
to cover the 23 so the 94 million
short shares this is gonna take them
roughly three days
and if you use the one week data like
here this
is going to take them 3.2 days all right
and we can see that this
is starting to get hot we are getting
closer
to some dangerous levels so once again
if you look at the past for example here
we didn't even have this all right
so it's you don't need to have it but
when you have it there is just
more chance that hedge funds buy back
the shorts and
basically for gamestop we were going
between
five and ten all right so this is the
critical
area so we are not there yet but once
again
if we grow up sorry here i was assuming
you see i was assuming amc at 40.
but for now imc is not at 40. let me go
back here
okay sorry for that uh so right now the
synthetic shot is at five percent
so the dtc is between two and two point
five
what you just saw guys it was when amc
is at the 50 level then it was to show
you to show you guys what is the gamma
squeeze because this is going to go to
14
and then the dtc is gonna increase to
three so you can see that for now the
option market is not huge enough
to create a dtc at five but once again
we didn't have it in jan
in january and still amc kind of show
squeeze but it was a very light shot
squeeze for me because
you can see that there were 45 million
short shares and we only went to 38 so
they only bought back
7 million shares but this was enough to
create you know some panic
on the upside so whatever let me go back
here
now it's at 10 all right
so here 5 here i
update my data okay five percent and so
we are between two and two point five
so i think it's interesting to just keep
an eye on this
so that we are ready whenever there is
some signals that the short squeeze is
approaching now one more thing i want to
show you guys is
some option strategy so for now
you have this kind of piano profile you
are basically long shells so if amc
let's say you have 100 shares
so you can lose 1 000 us dollars and you
can make
5 000 us dollars if amc goes to 60 for
example so this is your pnl profile so
basically your loss if amc goes to five
which is you know something reasonable
it's kind of the worst case scenario is
500 us dollar
and if amc goes to 40 you can make 3 000
us dollar
now remember what i showed you guys on
the option market i showed you
that the high
strikes have a very huge volatility it's
226
when it's only 130 for the at the money
strikes
this means that the options are more
expensive because market makers need
protection against this 10 million
shares equivalent short position that is
here so
what is smart to do guys is actually
instead of for example of having 100
shares
let's say you sell your shares i know
you guys don't like it but i'm just
showing you
what kind of strategies you can make
using options that are very smart
and that professionals are actually
doing so now your
piano profile is zero remember at the
five level you could lose
500 us dollar now let's imagine
that are making another strategy and
that you are buying
some call options so let's say you buy
for example
for 600 us dollars so let's put 600
right
500 us dollars so you buy 10 options at
the 20 strike
on the june maturity so i checked the
price okay so the price is here
so it's it's worth roughly 32
cents and the 20 strike costs 55 all
right we keep this in mind
and let's say we buy 10 options so if we
lose everything this is now the piano
profile so call option i remember you
guys you make money only if you finish
above the strike level at maturity
so this is the payoff max of zero spot
minus k
and if amc goes to 40 now
you can make 20 000 us dollar so
basically you have the same
downside risk so maximum downside risk
i remember let me remind you guys how it
was but you can make 20 000 if we go to
40
you were like this all right if you have
100 shares you can lose even more but
you're gonna lose
500 if we go around five but you can
make only three thousands all right
so this is just one example now this is
when actually i can give you some
cool stuff to do guys instead of just
buying a call
you actually need to sell what everybody
wants to buy all right because this is
what is expensive
so the high level strikes are actually
the most expensive one
so we're gonna sell for example the 35
strike white 35 because it's the maximum
level of my analysis so i would do this
if you don't want to sell the 35 you
find another one
but look so the price is 30 cents here i
buy for 15.
so now the strategy only cost me 240 us
dollars
and i still make the same money at the
35 level
but i decided to cap my upside
performance
and to reduce my entry price
and if you guys are comfortable with
actually
you don't want to sacrifice the upside
performance
or you are fine with spending more money
you just double it all right
so now you guys spend the same amount of
money as for the 20 strike
call option but you can make twice
as much profits if we go to 35 as
you used to for just the 20 strike call
so it's just about rebalancing your risk
and this is what is important
when you want to trade options if you
want to be on the right side you need to
sell the high volatility strikes and you
need to buy
the low volatility strikes this is
what we do so that's it for me i hope
you guys enjoyed this video
i hope i managed to explain to you how
to read the option
market information so the volatility
that is very important that is showing
you
roughly the probability of a share to
trade above a given level
at a given time it's the probability
that professionals are giving to it so
it's very interesting to
check this value and you can also
use the short interest that you used to
have
in the past to see when the squeeze
might happen you can use the dtc
and you can combine all this information
with your technical analysis to actually
build up
some very profitable strategies
that you know won't cost you too much
you can define your maximum loss
this is what is interesting about
options so i hope you enjoyed this video
and if you guys did please don't forget
to click on the sub
like and bell button so you're gonna be
the first to know when i upload anything
new
and stay close to shore i see you guys